so I went before Congress and we
actually testified and I said listen if
cellphone calls come brain cancer there
must be a big increase from 1970 till
today because nobody had a cell phone
that have you anybody looked at the data
they all looked around the room nobody
other day then I showed him the data
it's a totally flat line it hasn't
changed at all so it's very hard to
prove a negative yeah there's no data
that cell phone could frame cancer you
would think right handers you hold your
phone to the right side of your head
right more brain cancer on the right
head there's not so there's no data that
it does cause cancer but it's impossible
to prove a negative so no cell phones
there's no data at all that they do
cause brain cancer or airplanes being on
our airplane does expose you to some
radiation yeah and that's real and so
but does it kill kovat flight attendants
and pilots don't have more cancer than
the air right right so from that we can
assume that there's not a dramatic
increase in risk
what about microwaves my grave don't
affected it all no much just excite
water you can get in a microwave I've
even had a microwave for like three
years
listen you could have microwave now an
ibuprofen look what I've done from our
life